j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
des bas de société vous le savez le plus
souvent possible on choisit le décaler
de l'actualité du jour il concerne le
RSA le revenu de solidarité active
faut-il le conditionner à 15 ou 20h
hebdomadaire d'insertion c'est ce que le
gouvernement veut mettre en place et
test dans 18 départements reportage dans
l'Aisne tout de suite avec Jonathan
Dupriez
lent préfecture du département de
l'Aisne derrière ces murs des
allocataires du RSA parmi eux Chan 27
ans espère sortir de la galère malgré
des expériences en tant que préparateur
de commandes en grande surface le jeune
homme touche le RSA depuis un an 600
euros par mois environ il n'est pas loin
de retrouver le chemin de l'emploi à un
détail près ce comme à proposer mais
c'était à 10 km d'ici que mon profil
était intéressant c'est dommage que
j'avais pas le permis
je pense que c'est vraiment le permis
qui coin Sylvie sa référente va l'aider
à trouver un moyen de le financer sur
quatre mois à raison d'une fois par
semaine cette conseillère aiguille les
allocataires du RSA vers un projet
personnalisé et tente de leur donner
confiance en eux l'inconnu fait peur
déjà donc moi je suis là aussi pour
dédramatiser les rassurer leur dire que
les choses sont possibles et positiver
bien évidemment cette réunion s'intègre
au dispositif de RSA rénové que le
gouvernement test dans 18 départements
pilotes pour le mettre en oeuvre laine
aperçu un million d'euros de l'état des
moyens pour recruter 20 nouveaux
accompagnants et ainsi assurer
l'encadrement des 15 à 20h d'activité
hebdomadaires qui conditionneront
l'obtention de cette allocation mais
dans l'Aisne le projet gouvernemental
n'est pas une révolution il permet
seulement d'améliorer un dispositif
existant depuis 2019 et qui a déjà fait
ses preuves nous avions un peu plus de
18000 foyers locataires du RSA en 2020
aujourd'hui en 2023 nous avons passé
sous la barre des 16000 nous sommes à
15900 et quelques personnes à locataire
du RSA comme quoi les résultats arrivent
ça commence à porter du fruit il faut
être patient parce que ce n'est jamais
simple c'est jamais facile et nous
espérons vraiment que l'expérimentation
RSA rénovée que que nous voulions
absolument
faire
nous nous aide encore plus et accompagne
vraiment les personnes les plus démunies
pourtant ce nouveau RSA suscite
inquiétude et scepticisme dans l'opinion
de nombreuses voix redoutent un
sous-financement chronique de
l'accompagnement mais aussi les
éventuels sanctions envers les
allocataires qui ne se soumettraient pas
aux 15 à 20h d'activité hebdomadaires je
crois qu'il faut vraiment démystifier en
fait la sanction malheureusement elle
existe depuis toujours enfin en tout cas
depuis la création du RSA la sanction
c'est toujours un échec en réalité c'est
que nous ne sommes pas parvenus à un
accompagnement suffisamment personnalisé
donc en réalité les 15 à 20h ça veut pas
dire non plus que systématiquement on va
obliger à avoir 15 à 20h d'activités
quelle qu'elle l'idée c'est d'avoir un
accompagnement qui soit le plus
personnalisé possible laine n'attend
beaucoup du nouveau dispositif de RSA le
département l'un des plus pauvres de
France dépense chaque année 110 millions
d'euros pour financer cet allocation
faut-il conditionner le versement du RSA
au suivi d'un programme de 15 à 20h
d'insertion en débat tout de suite avec
Thibault guiwi bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir
vous êtes au commissaire à l'emploi
l'engagement des entreprises et vous
êtes chargé de piloter le projet France
travail marie-alete Grare bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes la présidente datée
des carmondes j'accueille également
Daniel Chassin bonsoir bonsoir Oui
sénateur LR de la Corrèze et
vice-président la commission des
affaires sociales Laetitia cruppa
évidemment est resté à mes côtés
indépendant j'ai dit
erreur excusez-moi je corrige tout de
suite le RSA et là j'espère que je vais
être plus précis on va essayer 608 euros
pour une personne seule 912 euros pour
un couple 1095
euros 1094 pour une personne seule avec
deux enfants 1276 pour un couple avec
deux enfants je vais commencer par une
question très générale Thibault Guy oui
pourquoi faut-il revoir le système
actuel
le système actuel sur le RSA c'est on
peut presque parler d'une faillite
collective quand le RMI a été créé
c'était un filet de sécurité on vit pas
dignement mais s'ils sont 8 euros c'est
un filet de sécurité pour pouvoir
retrouver un travail d'ailleurs quand on
parle de RSA sous conditions la logique
du contrat d'engagement pour essayer de
se réinsérer c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis Michel Rocard maintenant
si on regarde
quand ça va mal le nombre de
bénéficiaires du RSA augmente dans le
pays ça a été le cas sur la période de
2009 à 2016 plus 500 000 c'est le cas
encore aujourd'hui quand ça va bien ça
ne progresse pas il y en a pas plus mais
il y en a pas moins c'est à dire que les
embellis dans le pays ne bénéficient pas
au bénéficiaires du RS et à la fin et sa
cour des comptes qui qu'il a qui l'a
montré c'est quand même assez triste
comme constat 7 ans après l'entrée au
RSA on a 11% seulement des personnes qui
ont retrouvé un emploi durable ça on le
redira en détail dans un instant et donc
dans ce projet du gouvernement le
versement du RSA serait
passionné à 15 à 20h d'activité de
programme d'insertion évidemment ça sera
du cas par cas on va y revenir marier
avec grave vous avez écrit au 18
présidents de départements qui voilà qui
sont concernés par l'ex mirrementation
pour dire vous inquiétudes face à cette
réforme pourquoi êtes-vous inquiète nous
sommes inquiets parce que nous sentons
que les les bénéficiaires du RSA sont
particulièrement stigmatisés dans notre
pays du chef de l'État aux ministres
tout le monde y va de ces petites
phrases pour dire que les personnes ne
voudraient pas reprendre le chemin de
l'emploi que vraiment ils ne font pas
les efforts nécessaires pour aller
rechercher un emploi c'est un peu le
symbole de la France de l'assistanat
quoi si Je si je caricature absolument
je veux juste insister sur un point vous
avez dit 607 608 euros ce n'est jamais
ce que touche un allocataire du RSA il
faut quand même le savoir il y a
toujours
un différentiel qui est enlevé puisque
c'est une allocation différentielle donc
il y a toujours la location logement qui
est enlevée donc il reste 524 534 euros
il reste ça pour vivre pour payer
l'électricité les charges la nourriture
etc l'assurance on ne vit pas comme le
dit thibault-gli on ne vit pas avec un
RSA on survit et une dernière chose si
vous me le permettez c'est que
actuellement il y a 35 % de personnes
qui sont éligibles au RSA donc qui
pourraient avoir le RSA qui ne le
demande pas ça aussi c'est une grande
question que nous devons nous poser on y
reviendra évidemment dans ce débat œil
question générale votre votre opinion
d'aller chassa est-ce que vous êtes
favorable au principe de cette réforme
du RSA c'est-à-dire le conditionnement
du versement à un programme d'insertion
je suis complètement favorable parce que
actuellement il y a deux millions de
foyers qui touchent le RSA 4 millions de
personnes il y a 60 plus de 60%, ça fait
plus de deux ans qui sont au RSA et
37%, ça fait plus de 5 ans donc
cassoulet je rejoins un petit peu le
directeur en disant bon ben ça marche
pas suffisamment et donc il faut
accompagner davantage les RSA pour
qu'ils puissent retrouver de l'emploi
tout seul vous savez RSA ils ont des
devoirs mais ils n'arrivent pas à le
faire qu'est-ce qui normalement si vous
voulez ils doivent rechercher un emploi
et ils doivent essayer de s'insérer
professionnellement mais tout seul il
n'arrive pas à le faire alors les
départements effectivement font ce
qu'ils peuvent Pôle Emploi aussi mais il
faut remettre de du personnel à Pôle
emploi pour accompagner davantage les
RSA et et puis je termine il faut que
les RSA et bien puissent avoir des
entreprises mais qui sont d'abord
ouvertes qui sont les entreprises
citoyennes qui veuillent bien accueillir
et à partir de là et bien c'est possible
en accompagnant progressivement à
peut-être reprendre un emploi il faut y
aller très très doucement et et comment
que la marginalité
d'avoir droit à une deuxième chance le
RSA a remplacé le RMI en 2009 sous
Nicolas Sarkozy l'objectif est alors de
rendre le retour à l'emploi plus
rémunérateur que l'inactivité la loi sur
le revenu de solidarité active en temps
faire des revenus du travail le
principal rempart contre la pauvreté
c'est inscrit dans la loi et alors
comment ça fonctionne jusqu'à présent
alors le RSA est accessible personne de
plus de 25 ans sans ressources ou qui
ont de faibles revenus il faut avoir
plus de 25 ans habité en France de façon
stable être français ou citoyen européen
ou avoir un titre de séjour depuis 5 ans
minimum aujourd'hui on compte près de 2
millions de bénéficiaires 17% d'entre
eux soit 340 000 personnes de disposent
actuellement d'aucun suivi et on l'a
évoqué c'est précisément cette absence
de suivi qui pose question aujourd'hui
oui et pas seulement de pas uniquement
du côté du gouvernement à la Cour des
comptes a publié un rapport au mois de
janvier de l'année dernière dans ce
rapport on peut y lire que le RSA c'est
milliards d'euros par an pour les
caisses de l'État et surtout nous disent
les ça je le dispositif manque sa cible
puisqu'il ne permet pas de sortir de la
pauvreté l'objectif de retour à l'emploi
n'est pas atteint pour près de deux
tiers des bénéficiaires 7 ans après une
entrée au RSA seulement 34 % l'ont
quitté et on retrouvait un travail en
bref il y a une défaillance de
l'accompagnement c'est l'analyse que
faisait la cour des concilier 1 an et
c'est donc sur ce levier que le
gouvernement entendjoué avec ces
nouvelles récentes merci beaucoup Steve
Jourdain je vais redonné ce chiffre que
vous aviez donné vous aussi et qui est
quand même frappant 7 ans après une
entrée au RSA seulement 34% l'ont quitté
et on retrouvait un travail ça veut dire
que le volet insertion ne marche pas
mais ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas assez
de professionnels pour accompagner les
personnes dans la durée et dans la
confiance c'est de moyens humains
vous savez un chiffre très simple en
France nous avons un professionnel pour
100 personnes au RSA en Allemagne vous
en avez un pour 48 voilà mais si c'est
après jumeler avec Pôle Emploi du
nouveau nom peut-être ce sera plus
simple aussi d'accompagner il y aura du
personnel il faut accompagner il y a
deux choses d'ailleurs le reportage que
vous aviez sur sur la N c'est un des 18
départements qui est qui est engagé et
ça le dit très bien hein d'abord on se
rejoint tous complètement et d'ailleurs
le le rapport qu'on a présenté le montre
bien le 1 pour le rapport de un conseil
pour 98 personnes vous pouvez pas faire
un accompagnement personnalisé donc il
faut apporter des moyens aux côtés des
départements c'est évidemment leurs
compétences que d'assurer d'insertion
mais il faut que on investisse dans les
moyens de l'insertion pour qu'il y ait
un retour à l'emploi et puis la deuxième
chose c'est la coopération parce que
accompagner une personne en difficulté
c'est pas seulement lui présenter des
offres de travail c'est aussi des enjeux
de formation parfois c'est résoudre des
problèmes de garde d'enfant 32% des
bénéficiaires du RSA c'est des mamans
isolés avec enfants si vous traitez pas
à la question de la garde d'enfant vous
vous n'avez aucune chance à les
personnes ont aucune chance de pouvoir
retrouver un emploi et donc c'est un
investissement mais c'est un
investissement extrêmement positif pour
la nation parce que ça permet à des
personnes de retrouver leur dignité par
le travail 2 millions de personnes le
sénateur l'a dit c'est beaucoup plus que
les trois cent mille maximum qui avaient
évoqué Michel Rocard au moment de sa
création c'est bon pour les entreprises
qui cherchent tout à recruter faut-il
encore comme ça a été mentionné par le
sénateur ouvrir les portes et donc on va
accompagner les entreprises à jouer le
jeu de l'inclusion de l'insertion et
puis c'est bon pour la dépense publique
parce que ces dépenses d'allocations
bien c'est mieux d'avoir des personnes
qui se mettent à cotiser 20 millions
d'euros consacrés à cette
expérimentation donc 20 millions d'euros
pour 18 départements Daniel Chassain
est-ce que c'est suffisant justement
pour là on est vous êtes en train de
nous dire il faudrait réussir à faire de
la dentelle du cas par cas accompagner
les allocataires dans de bonnes
conditions et derrière cette question
combien va-t-il falloir mettre si on si
en généralise la disposition parce que
je reviens un petit peu
il y a la santé il y a le logement il y
a c'est un tout si vous voulez donc il
faut renforcer bon le département fait
ce qui peut au niveau social c'est son
rôle surtout mais c'est au niveau de
Pôle emploi et France travail où il
faudra davantage d'accompagnement et si
vous voulez il y a aussi des
possibilités à partir du moment où la
personne a découvert l'entreprise a été
formée a été accompagnée on peut aussi
alors peut-être que je vais le dire d'un
mot passer dans un projet de loi qui a
fait Claude maluré dont j'étais le
rapporteur et
et qui donc a été voté au Sénat
qu'est-ce qu'il dit il dit jusqu'à neuf
mois on conserve le RSA
jusqu'à 9 mois on cumule avec le salaire
de que l'entreprise alors attendez on
cumule avec un salaire de 20 heures
parce que si on montait on arriverait à
dépasser le SMIC mais justement on va à
20h pour la personne va percevoir plus
de 1000 € par mois et elle va travailler
20 heures et pendant sa 20h on va
pouvoir se former elle va pouvoir
intégrer dans l'entreprise s'insérer
dans l'entreprise et c'est par ce biais
qu'on arrive à sortir les personnes
alors on y reviendra au rôle des
entreprises mais je voudrais quand même
qu'on se pose la question de de la du
côté réaliste est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'allocataires qui finalement sont pas
en situation de revenir vers l'emploi
vous voyez ce que je veux dire ok c'est
et a fortiori de suivre 15 à 20h de
programmes d'insertion là dans la
réalité des allocations aujourd'hui dans
la vraie vie il faut déjà être
suffisamment en bonne santé comme vous
semblez le dire pour pour retrouver un
emploi ce qui est tout à fait voilà il
il faut comme le disait il faut aussi
avoir un logement un logement pouvoir
faire garder ses enfants donc ça veut
dire que les femmes seules avec enfants
par exemple elle rentre pas dans le
dispositif les droits sont liés tous les
droits sont liés c'est-à-dire que une
personne on ne peut pas simplement la
prendre sur le volet de l'emploi et lui
dire mais enfin pourquoi vous n'allez
pas travailler 20 heures vous n'allez
pas travailler 20 heures si vous vivez
dans votre voiture ce n'est pas possible
travailler 20 heures est-ce que c'est
suivre un programme d'insertion bon si
c'est suivre une formation je suis
d'accord mais c'est pas travailler 20
heures
c'est extrêmement explicite on apprécie
dans le rapport en fait derrière une
personne au RSA il y a plein de réalité
différente d'ailleurs il y en a qui
travaillent par exemple mais dont le
l'activité et le travail n'a pas suffi à
pouvoir sortir de la précarité du RSA
d'où les propositions qui ont été
portées par Claude malure et puis
monsieur Chassin d'abord un intérêt et
un cumul travail RSA qui soit satisfait
ça vous l'avez repris dans la réforme ou
pas mais alors dans dans ce cumul il y a
des il y a un cumul et c'est justement
on était en train d'en discuter c'est
pour être très honnête juste dans le je
le dis souvent dans les spectateurs
j'aime bien que les discussions
coulisses se passent aussi sur le
plateau donc là vous êtes dit non mais
dans le vestibule c'est c'est que on
travaille effectivement sur le le la
mobilisation des entreprises le cumuli
est déjà un cumul en fait entre le
travail
et le RSA en fait de 800 enfin jusqu'à
800 euros si vous travaillez vous
cumulez et ensuite vous continuez de
cumuler jusqu'à 1200 euros mais le RSA
diminue et ensuite ça bascule sur la
prime d'activité simplement là où mais
je peux pas me prononcer là maintenant
parce que c'est un peu court pour
l'instruction mais c'est vrai que le
sénateur me faisait remarquer que leur
proposition vient compléter un petit peu
parce que de temps en temps nous ça
s'arrête au bout de trois mois et ça
serait intéressant
étudié comment ça pourrait aller un
petit peu plus loin voilà mais ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que sur les 15 ou
20 heures en fonction des personnes et
c'est tout ce qui est en train de se
passer par exemple dans l'Aisne mais
dans les Vosges dans l'Aveyron dans le
Nord un diagnostic à 360 degrés quels
sont les appétences quel est le métier
que vous avez envie d'exercer est-ce que
vous avez besoin de formation un
problème de mobilité d'illettrisme dit
les tronismes tous ces sujets là on les
aborde et ensuite et bien on va composer
le parcours de formation d'immersion de
résolution de problèmes sociaux c'est ça
les 15 ou 20 allez ça c'est dans la vie
où il y a assez de personnes pour
accompagner les personnes qui sont au
RSA parce que excusez moi mais dans la
vraie vie c'est pas comme ça enfin pour
accompagner
brézinski fataliste monsieur et je vous
remercie de me comparer à Joseph
vraisinski qui est notre fondateur mais
ce n'est pas le ce n'est pas le souci le
souci c'est que les personnes au RSA
actuellement dans les 18 départements
sont invités enfin convoquer par Pôle
Emploi voir par une entreprise privée
qui est embauchée par Pôle emploi parce
que Pôle Emploi n'a pas assez de
personnes pour s'occuper de ses
allocataires du RSA et que ces personnes
d'une entreprise privée ne sont pas
formés pour aller rencontrer des
allocataires du RSA c'est pas si simple
je veux dire rencontrer des allocataires
du RSA c'est rencontrer des personnes
qui sont au chômage depuis trop
longtemps qui ont vraiment un quotidien
très difficile il faut il faut avoir une
formation pour cela il faut pouvoir les
comprendre il faut pouvoir avancer
ensemble sur tous les droits logements
santé éducation alors c'est aussi ce que
dit le sénateur LR de l'Oise Jérôme
Bacher je vous propose de l'écouter
c'était quand il était l'invité de la
matinale depuis Xéna
je vois que le Président de la
République a une vision très optimiste
des personnes qui sont aujourd'hui au
RSA
les côtoie pas donc il ne les connaît
pas vous avez une partie des personnes
qui sont au RSA dont on l'employé
militaire comme on dit voilà dans un
terme affreux
est nul ils ont besoin du RSA et pour
vivre et leurs conditions personnelles
ne leur permettent pas physique mental
désocialisation est-elle que il y a à
côté
utopique aujourd'hui à dire que tous les
allocataires du RSA pourront à faire ces
travaux
on dit bien je suis d'accord avec Madame
c'est pas tous les allocataires je pense
que il faut quand même dire on se dit
tout à l'heure mais il y a quand même
disons un échec puisque on est toujours
à 2 millions de foyers ça représente 6%
de la population quand même et bien oui
c'est vrai et il y a sûrement alors tout
ce qu'on a dit la santé de la mobilité
logement mais en plus une anxiété si
vous voulez pour les gens qui sont RSA
c'est qu'ils ont peur de reprendre trois
mois et après ils vont se retrouver sans
RSA et parce que dans le RSA il y a des
aides connexes si vous voulez vous avez
donc la carte Vitale enfin la carte
Vitale le logement
la complémentaire gratuite donc tout ça
si vous voulez il faut que ce soit
non moi je suis d'accord avec Madame il
faut qu'il y ait davantage de personnes
si on veut aller pour sortir une partie
des des RSA donc je repose la question
alors actuellement il y a 40% de RSA qui
sont inscrits à Pôle Emploi vous voyez
que c'est quand même pas normal il faut
qu'il y ait davantage d'accompagnement
avec Pôle emploi et le
[Musique]
être là pour accompagner les avocataires
du RSA soyons combien de personnes on va
mettre en plus et que l'on aura formé
concrètement en tout cas moi ce que je
partage complètement c'est que
l'accompagnement personnalisé ça veut
dire qu'on n'a pas trop de personnes à
suivre ce qu'on a mis en place dans les
contrats d'engagement jeune c'est un
professionnel pour 30 personnes et un
professionnel pour 30 personnes là on
peut écouter là pour les jeunes les plus
en difficulté ça alors c'est un pour 30
personnes en moyenne globalement pour
les jeunes on met en place en plus dans
le contrat d'engagement jeune on a des
jeunes qui sont particulièrement en
rupture des jeunes qui sont à la rue des
jeunes qui sortent et là dans ces cas-là
on travaille avec les associations pour
avoir des accompagnements encore plus
individualisés et sur les bénéficiaires
du RSA aujourd'hui parfois c'est 1% nous
ce qu'on dit c'est un pour quelques
dizaines c'est au département on va pas
on va pas décider à la place des
départements et nous on pense que c'est
un pour quelques dizaines donc oui c'est
vrai c'est des moyens importants mais si
ces moyens se transforme en retour à
l'emploi au bout de 6 ou 12 mois plutôt
que de laisser les gens dans l'exclusion
pendant des années des années c'est
efficace et c'est rentable pour tout le
monde qui va payer l'État ou le
département les deux mais c'est
aujourd'hui c'est la compétence c'est
les départements il est normal et moi je
rejoins complètement ce que dit le
sénateur que l'État lui vient apporter
aussi des moyens complémentaires il y a
Pôle Emploi aussi qui peut apporter une
force de frappe en termes de conseiller
emploi et c'est exactement ce qui se
passe sur le terrain et quand un
conseiller de Pôle emploi et à travers
social et pas une entreprise privée
comme vous le dites
comme vous le dites non c'est pas
vraiment sur ça il y a pas un seul
département dans lequel on est en train
de mettre en place accompagnement rénové
sur lequel on délégue ça et on sous
traite ça une entreprise privée c'est
fait avec des travailleurs sociaux et
des départements et des conseillers de
Pôle emploi et puis sinon on peut
s'appuyer aussi sur le savoir-faire des
plis des missions locales de ceux qui
sont sur le territoire font de
l'accompagnement
on va on va se concentrer encore un peu
plus sur ce qui est la principale
critique et d'ailleurs peut-être
est-elle un peu caricatural on va on va
pouvoir l'évaluer ensemble sur donc ces
15 20h de de programme d'insertion le
gouvernement s'explique comme le
ministre du Travail tiendrait
écoutons-le et il était le 2 mai à
l'Assemblée quels sont ces vins amateurs
d'activités ça n'est ni du travail
gratuit ni du bénévolat obligatoire
quand il travaille à contrat de travail
et rémunération ce sont des activités
d'accompagnement d'insertion sont des
activités de remobilisation ça peut être
des choses très classiques de la
formation de des ateliers de de réponse
à des offres d'emploi de rédaction de CV
nous connaissons tout cela ça peut être
aussi des activités et un parcours
personnalisé pour lever les freins des
freins à la mobilité des Francs
logements des freins liés à la garde
d'enfants ça peut même être et
heureusement dans un cas dans un nombre
de cas moins important des activités qui
permettent de résoudre des problèmes de
santé puisque la santé peut être
évidemment être un frein à l'emploi
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de prise en charge
ou des difficultés de en charge et alors
les critiques elles se concentrent sur
l'idée d'un processus ou d'un programme
d'insertion obligatoire Laetitia et là
ça devient intéressant et pourtant le
ministre l'a dit là et puis il a redit
après à l'occasion de d'interview non
c'est 15 à 20h d'activités obligatoires
ne seront pas inscrites dans le projet
de loi il a ajouté que c'est cet
objectif sera adapté ce mot-là est
important adapté à chaque allocataire du
RSA sans ajouter plus de détails alors
justement on va on va aller les chercher
ces détails parce qu'ils sont
intéressants ben oui parce qu'avant de
répondre oui ou non est-ce qu'il faut
des contraintes d'activité il faut
peut-être se demander Thomas à quoi sert
le RSA pour cette personne précisément
ou pour cet autre personne parce que
selon les profils la réponse varie vous
imaginez bien pour simplifier on en a
parlé là beaucoup ici déjà on pourrait
par exemple estimer que pour les jeunes
qui restent peu de temps par rapport aux
autres au RSA en moyenne et qui peuvent
être insérés ou réinséré dans le marché
du travail ces heures d'activité
obligatoire pourraient être utiles donc
elles sont légitimes est-ce que le sont
moins ou pas légitimes pour d'autres
catégories mais oui puisque c'est le
pendant effectivement de légitime
illégitime par exemple les seniors qui
auraient passé les 50 ans qui seraient
vraiment partie depuis très longtemps du
marché du travail ou toutes les
possibilités auraient été activées ces
contraintes ne serviraient à rien donc
là elle serait illégitime on ne va pas
juste uniquement les occuper ce serait
de la garderie ou alors il faut avoir le
courage de se dire très bien le RSA est
un dispositif d'assistance publique et
on l'assume comme tel
idem pour les malades les malades qui
sont sortis du marché de l'emploi après
de longues maladies pour lesquelles le
RSA sert souvent de béquille à
l'assurance maladie les contraintes
seraient vécues comme des handicaps et
donc ne seraient pas
utile et donc ne serait pas légitime
alors il va falloir regarder comment
c'est ce que le ministre du Travail
Olivier du soft est ok ils vont
l'adapter adapter le dispositif à chaque
bénéficiaire oui c'est bien tout l'enjeu
il l'a déjà dit par exemple pour les
familles monoparentales pour les mamans
solo qu'il y aurait des aides pour la
garde des enfants et que elle ne serait
pas obligée oui il ne serait pas obligé
d'y aller si les enfants ne peuvent pas
être gardés mais vous avez raison c'est
bien sûr tout l'enjeu tout l'enjeu c'est
de savoir comme ça adapté ce dispositif
à chacun et on va voir l'aspect positif
quand même de ce sentiment ce chantier
ce sera aussi l'occasion Thomas
d'affronter et de régler les problèmes
un par un celui de une assurance maladie
défaillante de l'employabilité des
seniors ou encore le manque
d'accompagnement social pour les
familles monopoles merci beaucoup
Laetitia Thibault soyons précis est-ce
que le dispositif les 15 20h de
programmes d'insertion est obligatoire
pour tous les allocataires du RSA
l'ambition c'est qu'il est plus personne
au bord de la route et donc ce qu'on met
en place sur le terrain c'est que 100%
des bénéficiaires du RSA soient
identifiés accompagnés figurez-vous que
il y en a 18 % ils sont même nuls par 0
accompagnement zéro contact donc la
première le premier objectif c'est
d'aller tous les rencontrer faire le
point avec eux ensuite faire le point
avec eux il y a des cas d'abord il y a
des cas d'accès aux droits tout
simplement par exemple à la Réunion il y
en a près de 3% je crois qu'ils sont
identifiés où ils pourraient accéder en
fait à leurs droits à la retraite ou au
minimum vieillesse il y a des situations
aussi de problèmes de santé où on
pourrait les accompagner pour accéder à
des droits comme la location adulte
handicapé qui est beaucoup plus
protectrice et sécurisante pour cela
donc on a une question d'accès au droit
et ça renvoie tout à fait aux propos que
mieux les identifier pour les aider à
accéder à leurs droits exactement je
repose la question du dispositif
d'insertion est-ce qu'il est obligatoire
pour tout le monde ah mais le principe
du contrat d'engagement l'inscription de
à Pôle Emploi oui parce que sinon en
fait qu'est-ce qui fait que les gens se
retrouvent dans des périodes d'exclusion
comme celle-là c'est que pas à un seul
moment dans leur parcours pendant les 7
années on leur a parlé d'emploi 74% des
contrats d'engagement aujourd'hui il y a
rien sur l'emploi le retour le retour au
travail il y a aucune chance sans
accompagnement que ça puisse s'appuie
fonctionner donc oui le contrat
d'engagement c'est pour tout le monde
par contre ce contrat d'engagement il
doit être adapté personnalisé en
fonction de la situation de la personne
donc ça veut dire qu'il y aura des
dérogations par exemple une femme seule
avec enfant est-ce qu'elle sera obligée
de suivre un programme d'insertion de 15
20 heures en fait les gens mais oui mais
les gens sur le terrain le contrat
d'engagement il est signé il est déjà
dans la loi depuis 1988 on va pas
déroger à ça simplement si tant que on
n'a pas résolu le problème de garde
d'enfants de la personne par exemple il
y a pas très longtemps j'étais avec une
maman trois enfants elle est chef de
sécurité
elle adore son métier elle a travaillé
pendant 24 ans elle a tout toutes les
formations simplement son troisième
enfant il vient de sortir de l'IME la
société n'a pas été en capacité de
prendre en charge de son gamin elle est
sept jours sur 7e déjà pardon c'est un
institutifs merci beaucoup des jeunes
pardon des jeunes en situation de
handicap cette dame elle a pas de
problème d'employabilité elle appelle
presque au secours pour que on puisse
lui apporter une solution de garde
d'enfant évidemment que vous allez pas
lui dire en plus de s'occuper 7 jours
sur 7 et 24 heures sur 24 de ces de ses
enfants d'aller la mettre en stage ou en
location ou que sais-je votre avis
là-dessus marie-alet Grace parce que
est-ce qu'il y a finalement selon votre
connaissance vous nous ramener aussi
dans dans le réel des allocataires des
bénéficiaires aujourd'hui du RSA
beaucoup d'entre eux qui ne seront pas
en situation en capacité de suivre ces
programmes d'insertion d'après vous
au-delà de l'obligation des sanctions
éventuellement associées à ce programme
simplement le fait de pouvoir y
participer c'est à dire que moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que j'aimerais entendre
de la part des allocataires du RSA le
fait que il rencontre des professionnels
qui leur posent toutes ces questions
dont nous parlons là or ce n'est pas le
cas ce n'est pas du tout le cas
c'est-à-dire que donc en fait la loi est
mise en place puisque l'objectif c'est
que il soit ils sont accès c'est
l'objectif j'espère je voudrais voir
qu'il y a vraiment beaucoup d'embauches
de professionnels pour pouvoir aller
rencontrer ses allocataires du RSA et
avancer avec eux parce que pour
l'instant ce que nous voyons ce sont
plutôt des sanctions pour ceux qui n'ont
pas répondu immédiatement qui n'ont pas
qui ne sont pas venus à la première
convocation et ça ça nous inquiète parce
qu'il faut quand même tenons compte je
vous l'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure mais
je le redis 35% de personnes éligibles
au RSA ne le demande pas et ces
personnes là
demande pas parce que parce que écoutait
remplissait un dossier de demande de RSA
vous allez comprendre pourquoi il ne le
demande pas 10 pages à 4 extrêmement
intrusives sur votre vie privée avec des
termes invraisemblable mais vraiment des
termes invraisemblables auxquels
nous-mêmes nous ne serions pas répondre
donc franchement pourquoi il ne le
demande pas voilà clairement compliqué
pour pour que une partie de la
population ne soit pas en situation de
faire la demande c'est ça toutes les
démarches administratives sont
compliquées madame mais franchement un
de vos confrères monsieur l'anglais sur
RTL l'autre jour a fait une chronique de
3 minutes pour dire ce qu'était remplir
un dossier de RSA et bien écoutez-le
parce que ça vaut le coup c'est qu'en
anglais nous dit effectivement ça doit
être compliqué vous parliez des
sanctions on va on va évoquer cette
question tout de suite et je vous
propose d'abord d'entendre ce que nous
dit la première ministre sur cette
question des sanctions liées aux
engagements des allocataires du RSA dans
la réforme telle qu'elle est testée en
18 départements c'était à l'occasion
d'un déplacement sur l'île de la Réunion
en écoutait Elisabeth borne en effet je
vous confirme que dans le projet de loi
il y aura la possibilité
de suspendre sur une durée courte
peut-être si c'est enfin pour démarrer
mais en tout cas il y aura un dispositif
aussi deux sanctions dès lors qu'on a
accompli de notre côté notre part de
responsabilité c'est-à-dire qu'on a mis
la personne bénéficiaire du RSA en
situation de suivre le parcours qu'on
lui a proposé Daniel chassaint pourquoi
faut-il des sanctions
mais il faut quand même qu'il y ait un
dans l'accompagnement si vous voulez qui
est un contrat réciproque entre Pôle
emploi et puis la personne pour dire bah
écoutez on va vous proposer des une
formation on va vous proposer de
découvrir l'entreprise je pense que la
personne refuse ça paraît pas normal si
et donc il fallait aussi un contrat
d'engagement pardon de vous interrompre
et si un contrat d'engagement c'est
normal moi je trouve qu'on est
complètement toujours pessimiste parce
que là on essaye on voit qu'il y a que
40% de personnes qui sont inscrits à
Pôle emploi il y a 2 millions de foyers
ça reste stable donc je pense qu'il faut
essayer est-ce que l'homme me dit Madame
il y aura 100 % de succès sûrement pas
il met mais je pense qu'il faut essayer
pour essayer il faut le département qui
fait des efforts si vous voulez sur le
plan social et le pendant c'est Pôle
emploi qui qui travaille aussi
actuellement mais avec France travail
vous aurez d'après ce que je comprends
davantage de personnel pour accompagner
vers l'entreprise il s'agit il s'agit
pas de rentrer dans des sanctions il
s'agit de petit à petit amener les
personnes qui sont loin de du travail
vers le travail il y a des gens là qui
ont 10 ans il y en a 37% qui ont plus de
5 ans donc peut-être que là-dedans ben
il y aura très peu de succès mais
pourquoi pas essayer plus de 5 ans de de
présence de RSA est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui parce que donc le la
nouvelle structure France travail ça va
devenir une sorte de guichet unique
c'est ça mais est-ce que ça veut dire
dans dans le cas des allocataires du
demi-sœur du RSA les fichiers de Pôle
Emploi sont pas
mis en commun avec ceux de caisse
d'allocations familiales ça se parle pas
mais ni entre les allocations familiales
et Pôle emploi mais mais pas non plus a
été mis sur le calme les associations
etc étaient d'ailleurs une des
propositions qui est qui est faite dans
le rapport et qui se traduit dans la loi
c'est que si on met pas en commun nos
données en fait on complique la vie des
gens parce que on leur demande moi je
partage complètement ce que ce que je
viens de dire marie-avette gras sur le
sur les modalités d'entrée dans le RSA
et puis la complexité administrative
qu'il y a mais le parcours n'est pas
fini une fois qu'on s'est inscrit au RSA
et on va nous redemander un nombre
d'informations en permanence
celui qu'on veut accéder au logement à
d'autres droits là-dessus donc le
guichet unique simplifiera c'est ce que
vous nous dites le partage des données
le partage des données pour faire en
sorte de simplifier la vie des gens et
puis aussi de limiter et de simplifier
quand même grandement toute la charge de
reporting qu'on inflige aussi aux
acteurs aux professionnels de terrain
alors que les données elles sont dans
certains endroits donc ça ça c'est une
organisation en tout cas qu'on qu'on
propose et qu'on met aussi au cœur du au
coeur du projet de loi pour demander
enfin pour que les gens puissent
coopérer sur le terrain faut qu'on crée
les conditions de la coopération
maintenant sur le contrat d'engagement
c'est moi j'étais éducateur j'ai
travaillé dans l'insertion et je crois
que personne est une employable après
évidemment il y a des personnes qui se
sont retrouvées en situation extrêmement
difficile il faut absolument pas
d'approche dogmatique mais on travaille
avec Emmaüs des filles moi j'ai
travaillé sur l'insertion des des
personnes qui avaient passé parfois 10
ans 15 ans à la rue et ben on commence
une heure deux heures trois heures mais
la dignité par le travail ça c'est
quelque chose qui est partagé par tout
le monde mais
bien la question des sanctions est-ce
que ça fonctionne est-ce que pour que ça
fonctionne il faut forcément qu'elle est
sanctions mais les sanctions en fait
dans un dans une logique de contrat
d'engagement réciproque pour pouvoir
avancer moi j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
avancé dans sa vie sans que lui fasse un
pas nous il faut qu'on fasse un pas la
personne doit faire un pas donc d'abord
que la société soit à la hauteur de ses
engagements parce que le droit
d'accompagnement c'est dans les textes
de loi mais c'est pas une réalité
concrète donc d'abord la philosophie de
cet accompagnement résolvé c'est enfin
d'être à la hauteur du défi et
d'accompagner les personnes à pouvoir
s'en sortir maintenant évidemment il y a
un contrat il faut le tenir et les
sanctions il y a pas besoin de les
inventer ok la radiation la suppression
c'est possible déjà oui ça existe déjà
Marie LED Grare votre avis là-dessus
avec l'expérimentation territoire zéro
chômeurs de longue durée qui permet à
des personnes qui sont au chômage depuis
trop longtemps de retrouver le chemin de
l'emploi à temps choisi en CDI au SMIC
donc c'est vraiment et on voit bien que
ces personnes effectivement il leur faut
du temps pour reprendre le chemin de
l'emploi il faut du temps il faut du
monde dans l'entreprise dans ces
entreprises à but d'emploi avec
territoire zéro chômeurs de longue durée
dans ces entreprises elles ont une
gouvernance particulière qui est plus
attentive à chacune et chacun parce que
on reprend pas le chemin de l'emploi
après 4 ans 5 ans 7 ans de chômage comme
ça du jour au lendemain même si Pôle
Emploi vient vous proposer une
magnifique formation ce n'est pas si
simple sans vous disiez tout à l'heure
qu'il fallait des moyens humains on
imagine il faut
c'est à dire que si on en est là et bien
écoutez un million de personnes et ben
parce qu'on en est là pour trop de
personnes dans notre pays et si on veut
pas les laisser sur le bord de la route
oui il faut des humains on l'a déjà
évoqué allez-y il y a l'entreprise mais
il y a aussi des Entreprises Adaptées où
on peut intégrer des gens à mi-temps et
qui sont aidé vous voulez alors quand
les gens sont malades il peut y avoir la
hache mais je voudrais revenir sur les
gens qui vont pouvoir être vers l'emploi
essayez de voir si ce projet de loi
cette PPL avec parce que tout à l'heure
ce que vous avez dit il y a un cumul du
salaire et du RSA 3 mois donc là si vous
voulez c'est 9 mois donc ça c'est la
proposition dont vous parlez tout à
l'heure bien sûr que alors faut une aide
de l'État bien sûr au département bien
sûr évidemment et on va terminer sur
cette question de du retour à l'emploi
et des entreprises parce que Marie
allait de garde dans le courrier que
vous avez envoyé à ses 18 départements
vous écrivez les plus pauvres ne doivent
pas être les variables d'ajustements du
marché du travail j'entends cet argument
la priorité c'est quand même que chacun
des allocataires du RSA puisse retrouver
un emploi on est bien d'accord mais
chacune et chacun d'entre nous souhaite
choisir son emploi ne souhaite pas se
voir imposer un emploi qui ne peut
absolument vraiment pas prendre enfin
franchement ça c'est vraiment important
il faut que ce soit discuté on va pas
forcer les personnes à aller dans un
emploi qu'elle ne peuvent absolument pas
tenir parce que on pense toujours pour
les plus pauvres on croit que on doit
penser les choses pour les personnes les
plus pauvres or elles ont elles-mêmes
des capacités des possibilités bien sûr
etc
et donc pouvoir discuter avec les
personnes qui les accompagnent et vous
nous dites que tout le monde
c'est comme ça que ça se passe comment
ça se passe c'est pas tout à fait comme
ça que ça se passe parce que on propose
des formations si vous n'acceptez pas
ces formations après il y a la sanction
qui va venir nous avons entendu madame
borne moi j'ai très bien c'est comme ça
sur le terrain monsieur le sénateur je
suis désolé mais c'est comme ça sur le
terrain non si vous n'acceptez pas une
deux trois propositions et bien là c'est
terminé la sanction c'est plus de RSA
les avocataires du RSA
terminer madame faut bien savoir les
allocataires du RSA se voit trop souvent
radié du RSA pour un oui ou pour un nom
je vous assure ça arrive beaucoup trop
souvent et ça vraiment
de choses qu'un des chiffres en matière
obligation de la recherche d'emploi
qu'on peut on peut être d'accord pas
d'accord mais aujourd'hui ce principe là
318 radiations
l'année dernière
318 sur 600 000 sur 600 000 radiations
donc en fait l'obligation de la
recherche d'emploi ça ne fonctionne pas
et pour une simple et bonne raison c'est
que de la même manière et on partage
évidemment avec vous le fait que on
accompagne les gens à trouver un emploi
qui leur correspond le mieux sinon ça ne
fonctionne pas mais ça ne fonctionne pas
pour elle mais ça fonctionne pas non
plus pour l'employeur moi j'ai jamais vu
un chef d'entreprise j'ai jamais vu un
chef d'entreprise avoir envie de
recruter quelqu'un qui avait pas envie
de faire ce travail en revanche là où on
a un collectif c'est d'accompagner les
entreprises à s'ouvrir à tous les
talents parce que l'inclusion s'ouvrir à
la diversité des talents ça c'est vrai
que c'est un sujet et donc il faut
outiller par exemple on a développé
l'immersion l'immersion ça permet de
tester pour l'un et pour l'autre
organiser la rencontre
économie sociale et solidaire aussi
c'est un effectivement un modèle qui est
un modèle qui grandit effectivement le
modèle de l'économie sociale et
solidaire merci à tous désolé c'est la
fin de ce débat écoutez c'est toujours
bon signe quand on a encore beaucoup de
choses à dire il était passionnant en
tout cas merci d'y avoir participé voilà
c'est la fin de ce numéro de sens public
je vous dis à demain vous pouvez
évidemment retrouver ce programme tous
les programmes de la chaîne sur notre
plateforme Public Sénat point FR et puis
notez son visage apparaître sur nos
écrans le prochain rendez-vous politique
c'est dans la matinale Oriane Mancini
qui reçoit Stanislas Guerini ministre de
la transformation et de la formation et
de la fonction publique en allant vite
je fais des erreurs bonne soirée